docteur Luc Boileau directeur national
de la santé publique du Québec docteur
Boileau bonsoir bonsoir Monsieur roi
alors ça fait drôle de vous reparler
parce que moi la dernière fois qu'on
s'est parlé on s'est parlé mille fois
d'autres choses et là parlons du SMAG je
vois que des ligues de baseball mineurs
des de soccer ce soir d'autres
organisations sportives vont annuler
leur pratique à l'extérieur ou leur
match à l'extérieur est-ce que c'était
la bonne chose à faire d'après vous moi
je pense que oui actuellement là je vous
parlez évidemment de ceux qui sont dans
la grande région d'abord de Montréal les
régions autour où est-ce qu'on voit
qu'il y a un smoke qui est présent les
gens peuvent le sentir en marchant ici
pour venir dans vos studios à
Radio-Canada on sentait bien les fumée
donc ça veut dire que il y a quand même
un taux qui est élevé vous avez eu des
infidélités avant qui vous ont signifié
les taux qui sont actuellement dispersés
à Montréal alors c'est pas une bonne
idée de faire du sport et d'être à
l'extérieur en voulant forcer avec nos
poumons notre coeur dans des contextes
comme ça on est mieux de prendre une
pause de rester à l'intérieur pendant
ces périodes-là qui ne devraient pas
durer très longtemps il y a une
prévision météorologique qui devrait
apporter de la qui nous disent qu'on va
avoir de la pluie ce soir puis même les
prochaines journées alors ça va changer
le portrait mais pour l'instant c'est
des bonnes décisions donc sur une
échelle parce que on va revoir la carte
Montréal c'était 7 aujourd'hui 9
Gatineau
à ce niveau là vous dites même si on est
en bonne santé c'est pas une bonne idée
d'aller faire un petit 10 km dehors ce
qu'on vous dit c'est que bien sûr
monsieur pour des personnes qui sont
plus fragiles des personnes qui sont à
se mettre ou celles qui souffrent de
problèmes respiratoires donc que ce soit
des maladies et puis de manière
chronique ou des problèmes cardiaques ou
cardiovasculaires eux je pense que
vraiment il devrait pas
s'exposer dehors plus qu'il ne le faut
idéalement rester à l'intérieur pour les
autres les gens peuvent juger s'ils se
sentent apte à le faire mais d'une façon
générale on juge que c'est pas une bonne
idée parce qu'effectivement ça peut
générer de l'inflammation pour des
personnes qui s'exposeraient de trop
surtout si on a un rythme cardiaque et
respiratoire accentué dans ces
moments-là on va ressentir inévitable un
peu des soufflements on peut avoir mal à
la tête donc ça sert à rien de tenter le
risque comme ça c'est pas parce que il y
a des risques énormes de se retrouver à
l'hôpital mais ça ne sert à rien de
faire des choses comme ça dans ça vient
qu'est-ce que ça fait techniquement les
particules ça vient irriter les voies
respiratoires et ultimement les poumons
quoi qu'est-ce que ça fait là
concrètement en fait il y a différentes
particules mais ce qui nous intéresse
beaucoup ici selon ce sont les
particules fines donc qui sont très
petites qui ont en boîte de 2.5 microns
en fait je vais pas rentrer dans les
détails mais est-ce que ça fait c'est
quand même c'est ça qui m'intéresse ok
mais ce que ça fait c'est que ça génère
de l'inflammation donc ça crée une
réaction inflammatoire à l'intérieur de
l'arbre bronché qui peut s'en aller
assez loin dans les poumons et pour les
gens comme vous le savez qui sont
asthmatiques ou dont des maladies
chroniques et respiratoires c'est
souvent le fruit d'une inflammation qui
est là donc on l'accentue et la même
chose à le respirer comme ça cette
réaction inflammatoire peut se disperser
au niveau de ceux qui sont qui souffrent
de maladies cardiovasculaires alors
c'est des inflammations qu'on a autour
des des vaisseaux sanguins des vaisseaux
principaux du cœur ou d'autres vaisseaux
donc on ne veut pas créer cette mé
inflammatoire d'une part une
surexposition de produits qui est dans
l'air et dont on peut se priver en
restant plus correctement à l'intérieur
les menuisiers ont travaillé avec un
masque parce que les particules de bois
ceux qui travaillent en construction
également qui détruisent est-ce que un
masque dehors est recommandé ici oui
lequel pas le petit qu'on avait de
procédure effectivement vous le dites
bien celui qu'on a le comme vous dites
de procédure le bleu le convoi souvent
puis j'ai vu en marchant ici des gens
qui le portaient c'était d'autres
raisons mais ça c'est pas vraiment utile
ça on empêche pas du tout les particules
de s'introduire celui qui peut être
efficace et le N95 mais encore faut-il
qu'il soit bien ajusté puis bien porté
ou faire attention le laine 95 d'abord
c'est pas disponible partout on en est
en stock pour des événements à risque de
maladies transmissibles tout ça mais
l'idée c'est qu'il y a une 95 ça
commence aussi un certain
[Musique]
on observe pour la covid c'est que
encore beaucoup de cas mais les gens ont
la plupart du temps des réinfections
donc c'est une infection qu'ils ont eu
dans le passé et qui avec un nouveau
contact font à nouveau une infection
elle est souvent moins pire elle est pas
toujours moins pire mais elle est
souvent moins pire moins importante
moins lourde moins contagieuses donc on
a ces cas-là malheureusement il y a
toujours des gens qui peuvent la faire
ou la refaire et qui sont dans des
dispositions de plus à risque avec des
maladies chroniques et on a des gens qui
qui décèdent de la covid encore
régulièrement presque tous les jours et
on a des cons on a quand même plusieurs
cas à tous les jours qui
s'affichent mais on n'est pas dans des
situations de vagues comme ce qu'on
avait vu c'est plutôt une période de
stabilité
et on le voit à travers plusieurs autres
juridictions n'est pas la seule comme ça
on est très content du succès que nous
avons eu jusqu'à maintenant sur cette
grande période pandémique là on est
parmi les plus
je vous dirais les meilleurs au monde au
niveau de la gestion là je tourne pas ça
sur moi mais toutes les équipes et tous
les enfants qui ont été faits les
mesures prises on fait en sorte qu'on a
quand même eu des succès excellents au
niveau mondial pour la mortalité puis on
veut continuer comme ça rien d'autre
vous inquiète docteur Boileau en santé
publique il y a pas de nouveau virus il
y a pas
une gastro virulente qui se promènerait
dans les écoles ou il y a rien qui il y
a pas de signaux orange sur votre
tableau de bord
vous le savez l'infilenza qu'on a eu le
virus respiratoires de les saisons vont
reprendre en quelques mois ou quelques
semaines on ne sait pas exactement
l'infinza actuellement à l'autre bout de
la planète et pas facile donc on
anticipe des choses on a aussi le mpax
de retourne quelques cas donc on a quand
même quelques signes de préoccupation
mais somme toute pour la covid ça va
pour l'in fluenza on s'en occupe aussi
puis les autres virus mais c'est très
possible qu'on se revoit sur d'autres
choses
pas d'autres choses de gros en tout cas
docteur lac Boileau directeur national
la santé publique du Québec à la
prochaine merci merci Monsieur bonne
soirée merci